[Music]
hello
and welcome in the 21st century
sexuality
is more explicit than it's ever been and
mostly sexuality is central to who they
are
yet we increasingly seek to eradicate
sexuality from our public lives
most people no longer think flirting is
acceptable in the workplace
and the rise of dating apps has made
sexual advances in bars and clubs
less common so should we see sexuality
as irrelevant to our everyday lives
and regard it as a realm best isolated
from our work and friendship groups
or are our sexual desires the key to our
identity
an attempt to remove it and attempts to
remove it from the rest of our lives
as a repression of our true selves well
we'll be exploring that question tonight
at this debate
as part of the how the light gets in
winter revel
my name is ron amita i'm your host for
this evening and i'd like to start by
introducing our speakers tonight
first of all we're going to have nikki
adams who works with the english
collective of prostitutes
a network of women working for the
decriminalization
of sex work and for sex workers safety
we then have mickey kendall who is the
new york times best-selling author of
hood feminism
notes from the women and movement forgot
and she writes on topics including media
representation
police brutality food insecurity and
other issues that impact
marginalized people then we have jasmine
alibi brown
an award-winning author and columnist
she writes regularly for the eye
newspaper
and is written for the new york times
the observer and a
whole wide range of other publications
her newest book is
ladies who punch an intriguing title
indeed
and olivia thane who is the author of
novels and also non-fiction work most
recently
why sex doesn't matter which addresses
the politics obsessions and
misconceptions of one of the most
important aspects of
human existence but before we go any
further
i'd like to hear our speakers opening
pictures
and each of our speakers will have up to
three minutes to present
thoughts on the following opening
question
is sexual desire key to our
identity who better to start us with
than yasmin alibi brown
yasmin please go ahead now let me just
say
i love sex i'm very lucky to get it with
somebody
who also loves sex and with whom i live
so i'm not being prudish and i'm not
being
fanatically puritan but i think this is
such a reductive
way of looking at identity um
and and actually in in my view
uh deeply disrespectful of of
a wide range of human beings you know
i watch a lot of animal programs we all
do animals
are driven by food and sex we humans
have much more to us than that much much
more
um what is mine oh it was very good
question
how do i identify myself my
brain identifies me my face
my heart um my limbs when they're
working
and yes sexual desire is a part of the
composite but it
it may not be at certain part of my life
i'm a very old person a much older
person than all the rest of the panel
so what are we saying here that when
sexual desire
wanes or becomes less possible or less
or more difficult or you're left alone
and are not with a partner
that you cease to be a being are we
saying that if you put
sexual desire so at the heart of who we
are
so i kind of think it's a part of who we
are
and like it or not a time comes
when sexual desire cannot be
the central part of your life like it
was when you were in your twenties
um and i think
it kind of reminds me of a
sex object objectification if you put
this at the heart of identity then
you're saying
you know sex and sexuality and sexual
activity and desire
is what makes you who you are um and
you know that's the society in which we
are now living
where for young people the pressure to
be defined by sexual desire and much
activity
is having quite a devastating effect i
think there's a very
interesting piece in the sunday times
recently
about young men really fit young men who
are really looking after their bodies
suffering from erectile dysfunction
and some of them were affected
by this society where sex is everywhere
and they don't feel
they're good enough or stud enough or
whatever it is that they feel
so i i think this is this is something i
i
really reject it's part of who i am and
part of
what many humans are but it's not part
of men
the the lives of many human beings who
live incredibly full
and exciting lives jasmine thank you
very much indeed for a very clear
opening statement and i think putting
our agenda right on the table there
may turn now to nicki adams nikki could
i take
could we have your view on this question
go ahead um
well i i think that uh sexual desire
sexuality and even our identity are very
uh quite fluid concepts and they're
often
determined by forces outside of our
control
and um you know we live in
a society dominated by the market and
none of us are exempt from that
and so um the those those
uh concepts are often dominated in the
same
by uh the forces that arranged against
us
and i wanted to um start with a quote
really which i think is really
great and really applicable it says um
culture is plays and poetry but culture
is also the shrill of the alarm clock
that rings at 6 a.m when a black woman
in london wakes her children to get them
ready for the baby minder
culture is how cold she feels at the bus
stop and then how hot
in the crowded bus culture is the spread
of the line sorry the speed of the line
or the wheat
weight and smell of dirty hospital
sheets
culture is making the tea while your man
watches the news on the telly
and culture is an irrational woman
walking out of the kitchen into the
sitting room and without a word turning
off the telly
for no reason at all and that's the
truth of sexuality too
it depends on your perspective and your
experience and how much power you have
in the society
i'm from the english collective of
prostitutes the sex workers collective
we see sexuality through the same prison
that we see our daily lives
that's from the point of view of the
single mum skipping meals to feed her
kids
it's from the point of view of the woman
on a zero hour contract who has to
endure her boss touching her up because
otherwise she won't get the shift she
needs to live
on the woman docked 30 pounds from her
universal credit because she tripped
over one of the obstacles deliberately
put in her way
and of the women who've got no recourse
to public funds whose friend offered to
put her up in exchange for the
occasional [ __ ]
and of the sex worker the woman who
decides to commercialize her sexuality
in order to get financial independence
and more control over how she lives
who she sleeps with how often and under
what conditions
so sexual desire is integral to our
lives but when our lives are dominated
and dictated by poverty and
overwork then so is our sexuality
the increase in prostitution is
sometimes misinterpreted
as an increase in sexualized encounters
but prostitution is increasing because
women's poverty is increasing
prostitution is not driven by men's
desire for sex but by women's need for
money
and so often it is an act of resistance
and refusal
the refusal of dependence and the
control
and the refusal of poverty and the
degree degradation that comes with it
thank you very much indeed uh nikki for
again extremely powerful opening
statement of one that sets the agenda
extremely
clearly could i turn now for our third
um pitch on this question to olivia fame
olivia
over to you well uh if sexual desire
really is key to our identity oh my
goodness what
what a sad sorry not we are
uh yazmin i'm completely uh with you
here feminists complain
about uh the objectification of women
and the male
gaze but it's a biological fact
the optic nerve is connected to the
hypothalamus which sends a message
down to the pituitary gland which sends
a message down
to the gonads and to complain about the
male gaze
would be like complaining that the lungs
were connected to the windpipe
men desire
women and other men who were pleasing
to the eye and men are the only villains
here
women desire good looking men
i mean that's what human beings are like
we desire
and we all do it we gaze
and was ever fuss uh if you remember
helen of troy whose face
launched a thousand ships and
it wasn't her her stellar career her
weight her kind heart
which launched those thousand ships
no it was her beautiful face
and that's the problem if you have
sex to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas